le coup de génie du dernier album de
quincy jones se bat comme deux blocs
c'est l équation hip hop égale be bop à
la question du magazine américain usa
today
alors où en est le roc en 1990 tom petty
répondait pour sa part récemment le rock
mais quelle rock le rock aujourd'hui
c'est le rap et il avait furieusement
raison le rap c'est vrai dix ans après
ses débuts aux états unis remplit la
fonction qui était celle du rock à ses
origines à savoir exprimer la réalité de
la rue et de la jeunesse
mais le rap ça n'est pas seulement le
médaillon d'or autour du cou les adidas
et le célèbre you me and my god
maichan non le rap c'est également la
violence c'est également le crack
c'est également le chômage c'est
également la marginalisation de toute
une importante partie de la jeunesse
noire et hispanique aux états unis mais
peut-on rapper en français alors qu'on
avait déjà du mal à rockets en français
on a l'impression que oui depuis
quelques semaines où l'on entend du rap
sur les radios un tout petit peu
seulement parce que le rap ça continue à
faire peur puisque on ne sait pas
exactement ce que c'est et puis le rap
on en entend parler à l'occasion de
l'actualité à propos des bandes à propos
des zoulous on en a beaucoup parlé donc
cet été et on continue de le faire à la
rentrée du rap en français ça peut donc
exister puisque on retrouve exactement
comme aux etats-unis désormais les mêmes
conditions sociales le rap en français
donc
ou pourquoi quand comment et surtout par
qui accepte ou pas en guerre des
magouilles dans vos adolescents sont
gérés mais à terre maintenant je prends
dur vivent dans une cité je veux dire
c'est pas véritablement vivre que c'est
je veux dire on met les gens dans des
tons les entassent dans des cités on les
met à part genre tous les émigrés un
parent
tous les gens compagne moyens qu'on rien
quoi on aimait à part alors suivi là
dedans tu sais un peu un autre monde
quand il ya beaucoup de gens qui croient
que que l'agressivité vient du fait que
les mecs qui bossent pas ou un truc
comme ça mais aussi l'environnement
toujours quoi je veux dire et puis en
plus il vit dans un environnement où il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ne les aiment
pas en plus quoi je dire et moi je me
compte dans le tas quoi bon les glandes
il n'y a pas 36 il faudrait savoir faire
tu peux comprendre et ressentir ça
est-ce que y'a pas de problème c'est
fait pour toi parce que ce système est
humaine a tué au combat mais je ne peux
pas m'empêcher responsabilité dans cette
émission parce que mon sens répond il
sans façon je ne prime pas qu'elle joue
pas de chez nous avec ma vie j'ai fait
ce que je remarque un peu d'une chose
c'est concernées ses voyages pour lequel
j'excelle je n'ai pas le don de dieu il
n'y a pas dans pool ça pue la pisse tu
carreaux cassés ccra l'eau c'est alors
il me qu'on se mette à la place d'un mec
casser ce pitch cas pas une thune dans
ses poches qui passe une soirée la ba
balle au mec qui se fait chier ben
qu'est-ce qui fait ben ils cherchent à
s'amuser à se distraire il cherche à
rendre coup pour coup quelque part et à
tous ceux qui sont sur terre les paroles
et les mêmes les gentils les beurs
robben était black ou ce que tu veux je
veux dire les gens n'ont rien à [ __ ]
de toi quoi tu peux crever quoi c'est ça
la vérité quoi et je t on est des êtres
humains on n'est pas des chiens et si ça
n'a pas changé c'est tout simplement
parce que les gens n'ont rien à [ __ ]
or l'état ils sont fous de savoir qui
est des mecs qui galèrent dans les cités
qui sont pour rien qu'on qui conte les
glands lucis cameroun ce que tu veux
quoi moi j'ai un pote en ce moment je
devais y passent 30 kg il apprend
qu'apple en crever
[Musique]